好 節目觀眾大家好
獲得空單既然到歷史新高
難免就會有一些擔心
老師 我們政策有沒有可能尬贏外資
其實我昨天是滿感謝王立委有提到
我們上次在電視節目中有講
說北東元件很多股票跌太多了
那你還在關緊閉
那實在是非常不合理
所以昨天我們看到金融會就臨時開會
就已經把這個條例改了
現在還有一樣東西 我真的也要呼籲一下
我是沒有資格去選立委
因為我這個 我能力不夠
我就說 外資心口不一這個
我希望說那個 有一些財委會的立委有聽到以後
你們應該要跟政 也要反應一下
昨天的道瓊唱歷史新綱
S&P唱歷史次綱
納斯達克已經重回到季縣了
我就真的搞不懂
為什麼外資昨天起貨要放空7523口
一放空完我就知道台積電不會漲
因為他一定壓台積電
壓台積電這個指數怎麼漲得上去
可是台積電是誰說要買的
是外資啊
3000塊也是他們喊的
4200塊也是他們喊的
老公可以把底下
你看看 昨天外資又賣了9717張
那為什麼他們可以去調高平等
拚命的就是要押台積電
就是為了他們的私心
他們希望期貨可以賺錢
期貨可以賺錢是誰可以賺
我跟你講那些操盤手
你把他們資料調出來看一下
怎麼會昨天美股
說不過去 道瓊創歷史收盤新高
昨天昨晚
我都真的這樣做沒有意思嗎
昨天我老師
老師我給你報告一下
這幾天其實你也在提說
這個借券的一個制度上面
一些問題等等
那剛好我昨天跟一位
非常非常大咖
但我不能不方便透露他是誰
他有跟我提到
第一個他就是說
因為借券當中
這也攸關券商收入
這第一個
那第二就是說
對在外資的報告
就如果之前我們也在節目當中
跟老師或者是投資朋友分享
就是说第一个
写报告跟操盘的不一样
那因为写报告的人
他曾经也去主管机关去解释过
他说其实这个我是给会员的资料
比如说我调高台阶人的目标要到3000
但是因为这个资料给会员之后
会员可能就给媒体
媒体就把它写出来了
所以就是他们跟主管机关解释是这样
那操盘归操盘的
对
那大家可以接受吗
那就不要写了嘛
你不要写就没有事啊
但他說這是要服務
我們可以寫嗎
我們如果說寫說
今天台積電要到多少錢
我馬上被罰錢
這個解釋不通的
因為你報當雜誌一寫出來
是全國都知道的那報當雜誌寫完以後你們媒體所有都會報啊這影響有多大啊那就不要寫啦你寫的反而是每天賣
那有意義嗎
那如果我們這樣做的話
你們會
你們會對我們福氣嗎
我們反而跟各位報告的股票
你看看偽創
沒有錯吧
好老師我們來講一下
這個就留帶
立委諸公民來關心
北極今天又上高了
我們也不能講目標價在哪裡
我只能講說
其實有些股票來講
基本上我們怎麼去看待它
那個我就不管了
反正今天壓台積電
大家有的也不多
只是我覺得台積電很可惜
那天拉到漲停板
好不容易站上季線
今天又跌破季線
可是很諷刺的是
那納斯達克已經要站上季線了
你不覺得很諷刺嗎
這是諷刺到假的
明明就出現一個島型缺口
他就是想盡辦法要把那個缺口封閉
那我也沒辦法
這個反正
我還是有的是台積電嘛 對不對
他有的是指數嘛
我明明看到美國股市昨天表現得那麼好
我卻看到了今天
棋子就是一直要壓 我也沒辦法
我只能說就我能力索機跟各位講說
有沒有哪些股票 你們值得要注意的
我一樣 我再把另外一張表
昨天有新的資料出來了
因為我一直認為MCU一定漲了
既被動原件以後MCU不漲不行 為什麼
因為6月28號 意發半導體就宣布漲價
是今年第二次
那我看到中國大陸的訊息是漲15%到50%
所以導播可以把MCU那比較表態給各位看一下
我昨天已經提醒各位你要看清楚了
那我今天請你再看清楚一下
因為盛群昨天拉到漲停板
今天稍微有回
盛群公布第二季的EPS是0.64
那我問各位一下一樣是季增的
松漢的季增是最多的
那股價卻是最低的
你們覺得合理嗎
其實股票市場上就是這樣 你用的合不合理
新唐第一季賺0.02而已 他今天會公佈他的第二季的EPS
今天最高新唐來到了130塊五毛
比松漢足足多了快三倍 你們覺得這樣合理嗎
那我必須講 有三樣東西我還是要跟各位講
你們如果有到光華商場去看
現在AIPC的標準配備一定有ISP晶片
就是高階攝影機要用的AIPC的高階晶片
這是誰做的?這是5471雙案做的
那第二個,現在市場上最流行的叫HPD
就是Human Person Detection
也就是直接翻譯成就是人在場的時候
他就會偵測到你
人不在場的時候
他主動就跟你關閉
我跟你講 這樣東西以後
基本上會變成標配了
因為現在大家都很重視隱私
所以HPD是最新的一個東西
Human person protection
我英文沒有那麼好
但是他就是翻譯成中文就是
人在場的時候他會偵測
人不在場 他就給你關閉
第三個東西就是
無人機的突傳系統
是發射端和接收端的
我必須講 我為什麼一直提這張股票
因為這張股票現在來到季線
你們有學過技術分析的
照葛蘭幣八大法則季線是往上的
所以一旦上上季線以後 它會有一波
我為什麼敢這樣講來 我們來看看菲傑老婆麻煩你放一下飛姐為什麼前兩天跟各位報告飛結你看一下飛結6206的飛結
我前天跟各位報告的時候
我就看到了 他即將要碰季線
有沒有
昨天碰一次季線 今天是不是重新站上季線了
那當飛結站上季線以後
他就是所有軍線往上站上
所有軍線至上 他就是要挑戰前高了
這都是我苦學技術分析得來的
你再看一看上次偽創
我為什麼跟各位報告偽創
你看一下3231的偽創
7月22號那天
他是選擇用跳空的方式
站上了季線
所以我今天為什麼再三的跟各位講說
季線很重要
因為松漢已經連續兩天來挑戰季線了
然後我昨天也跟各位報告一個很重要的就是
松翰再過兩天
他月線扣底會左下右上
倒不然底下你放一下547的松翰
底下放KD指標
因為我最近
跟你報告的股像
每一檔都創高
我不希望各位你收看
懷疑節目你錯過這一檔
怎麼會有人在KD指標
在低檔的時候
要來挑戰葛蘭幣八大法德的季線
也就是寄線往上回
這寄線是買點的
你們卻連看都不看
我還拿比較表給你看
你自己看這個財務分析就好了
這堂股票既然借券高到有170%
就是你昨天跟那個
一個大人物在聊的
他身份比較敏感
說實在我不能講
你當然不能講誰
但是我說這個借券就是
關乎著台灣未來能不能去尬到這些人
我想外資有一個武器
他媽有以後他借股票繼續來空
但他有跟我講
那我就說那政策什麼都沒辦法
他說暫時是沒有辦法的
然後他有說
所以我們要炸他
我們要勢力自強
對他就說投資人自己真的是要做功課
真的要去
我們沒有說今天我講實話一點
因為台積電線下跌
你看到指數下跌
你就被他以期以求
那我說真的
以後就讓外資來做
我們都不用做了
我就知道他今天
想盡辦法要補缺口
他要補哪一個缺口
你知道嗎台積電
台積電有一個缺口
就是7227有一個缺口
就是2305
到2330那個缺口
他就是想盡辦法
要把這個缺口給封閉
為什麼
因為一旦這個缺口封閉的話
就沒有導型缺口了
氣勢就沒那麼強了
對 你說這個很不舒服就是這樣
怎麼會有在美股大黨的情況下
他昨天硬要指數就是
我跟你講 我如果沒有在這
我以前得罪太多人就算了
反正我有一天 我如果退休
我就要寫回憶錄
我就要寫外資操作手法
這個明明在上記憲是給台灣股民
多大的希望
那我如果不講 各位你還不知道
昨天的道琼
收盤歷史新高
SMB是創收盤歷史次高
纳斯达克是来到了季线
怎么会我们看到
他体质要放空那么多
他放空那么多
就是不希望台股上涨
他不希望台股上涨
他唯一能做的就是
就是压台积电
那你看到指数就是跌
因为我们台湾股民很脆弱
就是看到指数跌就怕了
我覺得這是很不公平的一件事情
但是我也沒辦法
我知道他今天就是想盡辦法
要把那缺口封閉
因為封閉以後
我們這些學技術分析就告訴你
導訊結果沒了
他為什麼要這樣做
所以老師這樣子的話
就表示可能還是需要區間整理
對不對
不會再往下測
我跟你講
其實我們不需要區間整理就可以上了因為我剛剛特別跟我講Double到你看那個納斯達克就好了納斯達克已經來到季線已經要突破下降壓力線了
我們學技術分析的舊線論線
這樣看很清楚
廢半是碰到月線反壓啦
對啊 你自己看那個納斯達克
你花一條線來到季線
都不差欸 美國股市不差欸
我就真的不知道
他們寫報告
對你剛剛講的很好
寫報告是歸寫報告的人
那要賣的人是歸要賣的人
那你這報告寫下去
說會到3100會到4200
好不容易我們台積電
重新站上季線人
全民的希望都在台積電人
你卻這兩天
在美股上漲的過程裡面
用台積電來K我們
因為你要賺指數的錢
但是他們就說
寫報告跟賣操盤的不...
就是說要互相規避
但是實際上其實大海...
它不規避嘛
大海心知肚明怎麼可能規避
但法令上面是規定要
應該政策上面很少要規定的
但是我跟你講
我們前兩天我們自己...
我們就有在呼喊說
因為國劇這些股票跌太多了
被動元件有30...
就是說幾乎這一次被關緊閉的大部分...
不過老師
我們話又說回來
你本來股市就是一個多空競技場嘛
就這樣子
你就是要怎麼樣自保
怎麼樣賺到錢 你一定要練本線
你們不要受到外資期貨的影響
我們還有我們很棒的ETF
我們可以繼續奮鬥下去
我才會跟各位講說其實
你如果有收看我們節目的
你這一波
雖然我們之前有一些股票讓各位轉套
但是你看到了偽創
你看到了菲傑
我今天要各位仔細的看的就是松翰
我就是這樣子跟各位講
我們就是一檔一檔來
因為我從尾上的例子
菲傑的例子
我可以跟各位講
你把葛蘭比八大法的
你把它記清楚就不會錯了
為什麼
因為葛蘭比八大法的
告訴我們記線往上的話
其實回測記線絕對是買點
所以我前兩天
亞白我們在連線
你是不是率先跟各位講菲傑
你看菲傑長了幾天呢
你在看尾上
已經漲到要創新高了
我才會跟各位講
如果用比較分析來講
我也不要再去念外資
等一下浪費時間
你們就好好的幫我看一下
今天幫我看一下松翰
你看松翰是不是今天碰到季線
五四七的松翰
是不是有碰到季線
你們大家仔細看一下
五四七的松翰
是不是碰到季線
當他碰到季線以後
雙卷之比又那麼高
然後呢
你再看一下那張比較表
你們就可以知道了
MCU漲價的話
導播你再給大家看一下
30秒鐘看得對
除了商界之比
你看這張表
你不要等到8月7日公布的時候
我覺得太慢了
因為今天會公布的是誰
今天會公布的是新唐
新唐紀檢
都可以來到了今天來到
130幾塊
我只給各位一個想法而已
你們做不做是你們的
那我覺得台股
有時候不是說我要發發牢超
而是真的
然後現在看來就是時間換空間了
對不對
對
你就用時間換空間了
你們放心
我盡量我在我的節目中
盡量會挑好的股票給各位
好不好
我盡我所能
但是
我不怕得對外資
但是我該講的我還是會講
因為他們真的是為了指數而指數
你們不要受
你們不要上當
好
今天有一檔股票也很漂亮
突破了下降壓力線叫緊縮
如果你們印象有所及的話
我148塊的錢我就接到緊縮
他今天很生氣
突破下降壓力線又上來了
很開心
要大家抱得住
對 你們有這種股票就是抱老
謝謝你們 謝謝
好的 謝謝土老師